action potential is a rapid sequence of
changes in the membrane voltage which
flows along the axon at a technical
level action action potential is just a
change in voltage over time so if we
look at the graph it's a minuscule
change in voltage in a small fraction of
time
action potential is all or none and
action potential has a overall magnitude
of roughly 100 millivolt and which lasts
for 1 millisecond
so there are two important phase in red
you can see depolarization where there
is rapid influx of sodium ions through
the voltage-gated sodium Channel and the
later phase is repolarization where
there is rapid out flux of potassium
ions through the voltage-gated potassium
Channel action potential can be measured
by a technique known as patch clamp
here is how you can record the action
potential you can see upon injecting
specific current there is change in the
voltage and it happens in a sequential
fashion and you record the IV plots